good morning believe nation today's
message is start small over to you John
William first work that I did in the
Hollywood film studios was as a pianist
I in the old Columbia studios where they
had a contract Orchestra there was an
opening position for piano which I
auditioned for and I was hired by the
then music director Morris toll watcher
who the young people will not remember
so that meant it every day Monday
through Friday four or five days a week
i sat in the orchestra Columbia studios
playing under mr. Louis direction and
watching him under school films that
about westerns or or love stories or
scary films or comedies or whatever and
had a first-hand view as an orchestra
member of how this process of creating
him and fitting music to film went and
two or three years into my time at the
orchestra bear the same gentleman I said
would you would you prepare the music
for one scene for next week's recording
so I get one theme for next week's
recording and apparently worked out well
enough that he said would you do two
scenes for us a little short this week
maybe three months later so it was a
very good series of steps or increments
if you like to say I progressed from the
piano bench of sitting in the orchestra
playing the piano two young men sitting
not far from the music library writing
music for next Tuesday's recording I
think it's really important for
entrepreneurs that you have a big vision
but start small you have a big vision
but you start small and a lot of
entrepreneurs has a hard time doing that
you've got the two types of people the
first are the people who think big and
only want to activate your the dreamers
you're the nonconformist you have this
big vision for how you want to change
the world and what your role engine is
going to be how you're going to be the
next Steve Jobs and pick a dent out of
the universe I love it
you have to do something right and so
many of those entrepreneurs just have
these ideas and then you get frustrated
because they never get their big break
because they don't want to take small
steps they want to take giant leap
forward where you need to understand
that they take the giant leap forward
you have to start with the smallest step
and a lot of times people see that as
being beneath them well I don't want to
do that little tiny thing I'm a big
dream I'm a visionary I want to take
huge giant steps but doing nothing which
was what most of these visionaries do
they do nothing just sit on your idea
never get to you to that big giant step
you've got to take small consistent
actions and what that does it helps you
get better I helped you learn the market
more I hope to improve your skill to
help to improve your connection helps
you create more value and then that
small step becomes a slightly less small
step and becomes even slightly less
small step you get bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger and if you do that
consistently you look back and say wow
it took this giant leap forward and
people see it became this overnight
success but really it's because of years
of taking small steps and slowly making
those bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger so you need to act I love the big
visionary thinking I absolutely love it
you're going to take over the world have
a huge impact solve a major problem I
love it but you have to do something
start small you want to be the next huge
youtuber I love it amazing but you're
not going to start until you get the
gear and the lighting and the microphone
and the setup and all of that you're not
going to start do you have an editor and
the producer and all this stuff you're
not going to get that nobody's going to
give that to you and if you hadn't you
would suck because you have no
experience or practice so it's okay to
take out your phone and start recording
like that sorry take action get better
and those small stats will lead to the
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
step it's so important so one of you
were just lost in your dreams that you
don't do anything you got to do
something then there's the other
entrepreneurs who start small but then
they also think small there is no bigger
vision they stay stuck where they are
and maybe that's a part time income
maybe that's even a full time income
maybe that's even this point were you
you've built it to the point where you
can provide opportunities for other
people as well you've got a team
what your vision is still limited those
people could push the sync figure to
have a greater impact you're great at
executing but you're not great at
pushing harder because you're stuck in
always trying to be practical mode and
so there aren't that many entrepreneurs
that are good balance of both where you
have the big vision but you're willing
to grind it out and do all the small
steps and so whatever category you fall
into you could learn from going to the
other side the visionary needs to learn
from the hustler who will grind out
every little small step and that Brian
your husband could learn from a
visionary and thinking bigger how to
exploit their compass and so the
question is a today is I'm curious I
want to know from you your big vision
number one what your big vision is and
to what the small step you're going to
do today is to build that business a
little bit further leave in the comments
below I'm going to join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Omar car mats Omar thank
you so much for picking up a copy of my
book your one word I really really
really appreciate it and hope you're
enjoying the read thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you how to
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is let's love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events alright believe
nation for those of you who want a
little more knowledge on starting small
here are some extra bonus clips that I
think you'll enjoy that's way to
establish yourself on the internet is to
start small once again be humble
approach well first of all you got
making music is correct with many [ __ ]
online to a music
but once you feel like your music is
true and correct stay humble start small
goes to light from a smaller blog that
you know they don't get as many here
sister now writes but maybe they'll post
your [ __ ] if they like it you know
showers and dg2 pc know like part of me
do and people like smaller blogs it up
where perfection you know maybe if they
finish we got a shot like they put it up
to the way better chance that the big
blog to pick it up especially after
seeing it no the perfection picture does
we may be dc-to-dc put it up maybe quite
amusing for them that is three it's more
small applause that still have good
followers at upon your sit ups for the
big of laws like it some dope boys might
pick it up now and then after they sing
on that that's the best way to start a
big dream and then to start small no but
the internet is not stand all be all
matters a lot more to go many
entrepreneurs fail due to over funding
so you look we're in a beautiful
location in Terraria el Moreno it's a
legendary family in the restaurant care
business and they've been doing this for
years with you look at somebody that
decides that they can close and they
want to work on grandma's recipes
they'll go out and you'll get a hundred
thousand dollar loan they'll open up a
restaurant they have no experience doing
that they'll have a beautiful place
great staff but they didn't sell not one
piece of food in their entire life and
they didn't understand the operation of
the business eight months in a year in
when they realize why they don't have
any customers so they didn't have a
customer base in the beginning they have
a hundred thousand dollar loan now on
the business and they haven't figured
out the business then all of a sudden
they have to close down I thought of
literally with 800 was a hat and that
was the beginning what do we my advice
to students who want to start an
organization like wipro it's you know
the realities you'll have to start small
like we started small and you you must
have you must have a very clear
understanding of why you want to do it
and what focus you want to build and the
focus you want to build in terms of
starting an organization something
that's nothing deeply passionate inside
you because you're going to go through
ups and down in many cases you're going
to fail certainly in paths of tio your
journey you're going to have major fail
so unless you have a very clear
commitment to the focus which you
in terms of what you want to build
successfully and have the flexibility to
change that focus because you've not
judged the market properly the markets
don't run after you in and you have to
run afterwards the market demand is or
the market demand you can create but you
have to be persistent and you have to be
prepared to make sacrifices because you
will have to make sacrifices in the
early stages and some very major
sacrifice and most of them will be
financial sacrifice because you won't
get cash flows the way you hope to get
cash unless you have a brilliant genius
idea then you'll get cash